la central nuclear de sapo orilla se
volvió el foco de la guerra de la
información entre moscú y kiev el sábado
rusia que ocupa el lugar desde
principios de marzo acusó al ejército
ucraniano de haber disparado 17
proyectiles contra el sitio 4 cayeron en
el techo del edificio especial número 1
donde se encuentran 168 conjuntos de
combustible nuclear estadounidense de
westinghouse falso según el operador
nuclear ucraniano que denuncian nuevos
ataques rusos a la central emitiendo una
advertencia debido a los bombardeos
periódicos la infraestructura de la
planta ha quedado dañada hay riesgos de
fuga de hidrógeno y de pulverización
radioactiva y el riesgo de incendios
alto en las últimas semanas la planta ha
sido objeto de varios ataques un
edificio en el que se ha almacenado
combustible fresco habría sido dañado
pero el riesgo de contaminación es muy
bajo por el momento según esta experta
en estos casos el combustible fresco no
es radioactivo es posible que haya polvo
de uranio que se pulveriza por el lugar
pero no una liberación de radioactividad
a la atmósfera en absoluto
los expertos del organismo internacional
de la energía atómica muy esperados por
las autoridades ucranianas visitaran el
lugar la próxima semana para realizar
una misión de evaluación